alors coronavirus espionnage
hong kong taiwan droits de l'homme
rivalité technologique fermeture des
consulats
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
relations entre la chine et les
etats-unis sont tendues ce qui n'a
pourtant pas empêché pékin et washington
de signer le 15 janvier 2020 un accord
de phase 1 censé mettre fin à deux
années d'intenses guerre commerciale
on aurait pu croire qu'on était sur la
bonne voie sauf que moins de 10 jours
plus tard bimco vite 19 et sa
conséquence directe la plus grave crise
économique depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale ajoutez à cela le fait que
pékin et washington s'accuse d'être à
l'origine de la propagation du
coronavirus et vous obtenez un
rétropédalage de la chine sur ses
engagements vis-à-vis des etats-unis
alors qu'on parlait quand même de 200
milliards de dollars d'échangés
commerciaux rang fin juin seuls 46% des
achats prévus à cette échéance avait été
réalisé mais les deux gouvernements nous
assure tout de même que tout va bien
les ministres du commerce des deux pays
entretiennent par téléphone et publient
dans la foulée un communiqué commun les
deux parties constate des progrès ils
sont déterminés à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer la réussite de
l'accord les deux parties sont tombées
d'accord pour créer les conditions et
l'atmosphère permettant de continuer à
faire progresser la mise en oeuvre de la
première phase de l'accord économique et
commercial sino américain pourquoi ce
retournement de situation
business is business même si donald
trump et son équipe ne portent pas pékin
dans leur coeur bien au contraire il
faut bien mettre de l'eau dans son vin à
un moment donné la présidentielle de
novembre approchent trump est en
difficulté dans les sondages et il est
crucial pour lui de tenir sa promesse
envers les agriculteurs américains
il faut dire que la guerre économique
avec la chine les a mis en grande
difficulté
pékin ayant réduit ses achats de
produits telles que le soja et il
comptait sur cet accord promis par trump
pour rebondir
washington temporise pékin joue le jeu
mais est ce pour autant la fin des
tensions entre les deux pays
si c'était aussi facile tout le monde
serait copains comme cochons car au delà
de la rivalité commerciale la chine et
les etats unis se livre également une
guerre technologique
washington cherche à forcer la vente de
l'application tik tok qui appartient au
groupe chinois buydens et que les
américains soupçonne d'espionnage
tik tok porte plainte invoquant la
liberté commerciale
trump peut également empêcher huawei le
géant chinois des télécoms de nouer des
contrats relatifs à l'installation des
fameuses antennes 5g la pékin dénonce un
véritable harcèlement unilatérale de la
part de washington et plaide pour
l'ouverture des marchés et puis il ya
aussi la question de taiwan et de hong
kong
les nouvelles lois sécuritaires instauré
par pékin dans l'ancienne colonie
britannique sont jugés trop pop récifs
par washington qui a suspendu trois
accords bilatéraux avec hong kong la
semaine dernière pékin répond mêlez vous
de vos affaires et même les autorités
hongkongaises sont furieuses car elles
refusent de jouer le rôle de fusible
dans le rapport de force sino-américain
taïwan même son cloche adopté lors de sa
convention nationale le 21 août la
plateforme 2020 du parti démocrate
américain pour les prochaines élections
dit ne plus comprendre l'adhésion au
principe d'une seule chine
traduction taiwan bas pour nous c'est
plus vraiment la chine
désolé sauf que le principe d'une seule
chine énoncée en 1997 par deng xiaoping
est la pierre angulaire de la politique
du gouvernement chinois s'agissant de
taïwan
inutile de préciser que pékin demande
encore une fois poliment à washington de
se mêler de ce qui le regarde la
question de taiwan et la question la
plus importante et la plus sensible dans
les relations sino américaines
le principe d'une seule chine est un
fondement politique de nos relations
bilatérales et représente aussi le
consensus de la communauté
internationale nous exhortons les
parties concernées à respecter
sincèrement le principe d'une seule
chine et à traiter les questions liées à
taïwan de manière prudente et appropriée
l'accord commerciales nouées entre les
deux pays ne semble pas à même de venir
à bout des vieilles rengaines en tout
cas tant que washington s'obstinera à
mettre son nez partout considérant qu'il
en a le droit voire le devoir
ce qui n'arrange rien à ses relations
avec d'autres puissances tout aussi
influente que lui